The Story of "So-to" Hachioji
"So-to" is the name of a town that prospered in the silk industry as a mulberry town.
"So-to" is a town that prospered in silk industry.
450 years ago, Ujiteru made a town around Hachioji Castle.
Merchants traded textiles in this town.
Hachioji Castle was lost in the Edo Period.
However, the town survived in a different place.
This town was called Hachioji-juku and had grown with the silk industry.
After that, the silk was brought from Hachioji to Yokohama...
...for export to foreign countries.
The road that silk was brought to Yokohama is called "Silk Road,"...
...and the development of the silk industry created the wonderful textile "Tama-ori".